they came in their thousands to see
mandela for the last time
for some the emotion was too much
some were escorted away from the
government buildings overlooking
pretoria where mandela's body will spend
two more days lying in state
cameras are banned from the viewing area
mourners can see mandela's face through
a pane of glass above his coffin you
know
just the same way you know he used to
used to see him when he was
that old man the old man who used to box
and all that he reminded me of that time
he was wonderfully dressed and i really
liked the shirt that he was wearing he
really looked like the madiba that was
of the people like he really was still
among us and just resting
at the end of the day the coffin was
removed and taken to a military hospital
where it's been kept overnight
mandela's remains will be returned in
the morning to lay in state again
many thousands more people are expected
to view the icon of south africa's
anti-apartheid movement before his
burial on sunday